on today's show we're going to talk to a
young mom with three kids
under the age of five whoa we're also
going to talk to a woman
who's having trouble speaking the same
love language as her husband
and in a special show we're going to
talk about goals
and a different way to look at new
year's resolutions this year
stay tuned
[Applause]
hey what is up this is john and this is
the dr john delony show
we're taking your calls about your life
and your relationships
your dilemmas your challenges i want to
help you rethink re-examine and
reconsider your life
how you talk to yourself how you talk to
your kids how you talk to those
you like and how you talk to those you
don't like right we're talking about
love and loss
and family issues and in this special
show we're going to take a few calls and
we're going to talk about
goals we're going to talk about the new
year how that works
and again i'm into the business of
redefining how we approach some of these
things and so want to challenge
everybody
as you consider new year's goals we're
going to do a special new year show
in a couple of shows but i want to prime
the pump i want people to start thinking
about it
and possibly a way to think about goals
a little bit differently so
we're so glad you're here if you are a
parent
a teacher a healthcare worker somebody
who is
taking care of our water supply
electricians out there in the middle of
the night
dealing with winter storms and power
outages
whatever you're doing thank you
i'm grateful for you i'm glad you're
plugging in
if you are stuck at some family member's
house and i'm talking to you
my little brother who's staying at my
house right now him and his wife y'all
are stuck here
it's cool man right it's cool shake it
off
if you're stuck at your family's house
if you didn't get to see your family i'm
glad you're listening glad you're here
with us
so let's go straight to the calls let's
go to jenny in dallas texas
jenny good morning how are we doing good
how are you
i'm doing well i'm doing well so you're
there in texas
how can i help this morning um
so i am a mom of three little ones and
um it gets pretty chaotic in my house
and um
i constantly find myself responding to
my kids
in anger so i really need help figuring
out
how to change that because i know that
my anger is damaging
my relationships with my kids
how old are they um i have a
five-year-old
a three-year-old and a one-year-old whoo
so you're in the thick of it huh
yes tell me about your five-year-old
um well she is um
she's in kindergarten and she's very
quiet and barely says
a word outside our home um
and so she's always like on her best
behavior at school so
when she comes home she just kind of
lets it all out
there you go so what about your what
about your middle child
um so he
he actually is typically the happy one
but
um lately he he's just kind of been
really fussy and um just kind of cries
about everything
um and what about your wonderful really
sure where that's coming from what about
your wife um
so he's probably the most challenging of
all of them
um he's extremely clingy he's never
really been a content baby
and um he's only happy when i'm holding
him or feeding him or playing with him
and so i can't
can't get anything done and i can't get
any quality time with my older kids
so um
what about dad is he present yes
good guy yes how
when i say present what does that mean
to you
um well he is
um he's very supportive i mean he is
always there he helps me whenever i need
help um
so i mean he just you know has to work
during the day and so
i'm just ready for him to be done with
work by the end of the day
and yeah so
number one i want you to hear me say
loud and clear you're not crazy and
you're not
nuts okay
okay do you trust me
yes okay you have three humans under the
age of five
i'm about to have a five-year-old too
and whoa
and you've got two underneath that
so you are not nuts everything in your
house is crazy
everything feels out of place and
everything feels like
you are just reactive is that right
yes and so then you respond in anger
i want you to think of anger as a gift
okay anger just points you towards
something that you care about
it just points you towards something
that matters to you that's important to
you
and so when you say you respond in anger
what does that mean
um well you know i get really
impatient and irritated and annoyed and
so i'm just i'm really short with them
so i guess this is my
harsh tone of voice when you find
yourself impatient what do you want
the other situation to be and what i
mean by that is
you must have a picture in your head of
a clean kitchen or a perfect
perfectly ordered children standing in a
row waiting for
to to ask you what they can do to help
you with your day
or uh you want to finally take a shower
or you want your body to finally be
yours and not having people clamoring
you don't want to feel like a you know
like a garage anymore right where people
are just
using you as a as a as a space that
they're claiming as their own right
all those and you get short and
frustrated
what is the picture in your head what do
you want on the other
side of that um
i guess i just uh expect them to not
uh do the things they know they
shouldn't do you know but
the same things that happen every day um
i just feel like it just repeats itself
over and over again and so
i guess that's just frustrating to me um
for sure
i want you to feel i want you to feel
totally at peace
with the frustration it's normal here's
a couple of
things you can do and begin to work
through okay
so you can't control the fact that a
five-year-old's a
that they think things are funny or
scary or loud
right you can give them firm boundaries
this morning my daughter was
screaming and i don't mean screaming i
mean like
heavy metal singer screaming at my son
for something i thought he was
had pulled a hatchet out and this was it
and i went up to see what was going on
and it was something that was so minor
and benign
and i just sat down and said you cannot
talk to my son like that
you can't talk to your brother like
right so there's some there's certain
boundaries
certain things you can't do and there's
certain things that are just
developmental
that are just three-year-olds and
one-year-olds and so the only thing in
that equation
you can control is you right
and if you wait until you're frustrated
or exhausted or somebody's been hanging
on you all day
if you wait until your three o'clock
plan
doesn't work out because one kid took a
nap too long or one was too short or
your husband had to stay at work later
if you wait until those moments then
that's like the fire's already out of
the barn right it's already burning down
your pasture
it's too late and so what i want to
challenge you
to do is this number one
be really graceful with yourself
often i find moms of one kid much less
three
the person you stop taking care of is
you
the person you stop asking what do i
need right now
is you and i know that sounds like a
privileged statement because some moms
would love to do things for themselves i
don't freaking have time i've got to go
work two jobs i've got to fill in the
blank
but i want you to start being kind to
yourself and start asking yourself what
do you need
how is putting on your oxygen mask today
going to help
and occasionally that means asking your
husband i need you to help me in this
way because i've got to go work out i've
got to go for a walk
i've got to shower alone for the first
time in however long
and i need you to adjust your work
schedule or
i need to call a friend over a few days
a week just to sit with my kids for an
hour
while i just act like a human for a
minute
or fill in the blank fill in the blank
and of course all this is messier
because of corona i get all that
but i want you to start thinking through
number one what are the things that you
need
not what are the things that i have to
do have to do have to do
in my house this is we've had some hard
conversations because my wife
has a picture of a kitchen that's always
clean always 24 7. like
i will not do anything after this until
that's done and
she realized but i need to do this too i
need some quiet time i need some writing
time i need some exercise time i need
some fill in the blank time
so i want you to take the put the
pictures of the way you're trying to
keep things together right now that's
making you frustrated because you can't
make those pictures a reality because
you got
three miniature humans running around
i want you to put those down and say
what do i need number two
i want you to get with your husband and
actually come up with a tried and true
plan what is a what is a plan for a week
going to look like
as opposed to reaction you can't control
reactive five
three and one year olds they just have
shorter naps sometimes they just don't
take a nap at all sometimes they just
have
rocket explosive diarrhea sometimes they
just fill in the blank
you can come up with a schedule and a
plan and that means you and your husband
are going to sit down
and you're going to plan the week you're
going to put it on a note card you're
going to put it in a
calendar you're going to put it in some
sort of semblance of
and that might mean meal planning that
might mean saying on monday hey husband
i need you to pick up
dinner these two nights or you're going
to come and cook but
plan these things ahead of time and it
makes so much less
reaction and then hold those planes
really loosely
let him know hey at four o'clock i may
call you and say you're doing dinner
tonight and he's gonna have to roll it
because you got three miniature humans
you may call and say we are going out
tonight
because i got three minutes of humans
and i can't take another second of this
you may have to call a neighbor and say
hey so-and-so is still sleeping and i
don't want to wake him up
but i've got to go pick up such and such
and you've got to come up with a team
but
all that starts with the plan then the
third thing is promise yourself
we could get into this deeper we're not
going to on this show
your anger reaction is probably
something you watched and experienced
promise yourself that you will not pass
that on to your kids
promise yourself promise yourself jenny
you're not going to yell at your kids
you're going to come up with different
alternative ways to help them learn
different alternative ways you're not
going to pass that on to them so that
when
they're around their kids and friends
and family that's going to be their only
response mechanism too
and that means you're going to have to
learn whether it's with a counselor
whether it's
in a agreement with your husband whether
it's reading the right book
it's you're going gonna have to learn
and practice non-reactive ways of
responding to your kids and that is hard
and it's
lifelong it's lifelong and then one
final thought
your one-year-old is going to live your
one-year-old is going to live
they need to learn some boundaries and
that's hard your other kids need your
full attention
eye contact connection and so there may
be times when you have to
alternate nap times you have to
alternate
play times you've got to do some
creative scheduling there that's going
to make you exhausted
but that each kid is going to get their
connected time with you
and it's going to feel awkward but
you're investing time in the middle of
the day that's going to pay off at the
end of the day because you're not going
to have fried disconnected kids there
so that's a few thoughts few ideas
i hope people will respond in the
youtube comments with things that have
worked for them
right feel free to send me some emails
and i will circle back folks if you've
got things that work for you
um the one glaring thing here is i'm not
a mom of three tiny little kids i've
just sat
and talked to them and met with them
over the years and it starts with grace
it starts with planning and it starts
with a commitment to not be reactive but
thank you so much for that call jenny
let's go to nicole in seattle washington
nicole
what's happening hi john how are you for
taking my call
hey thank you for calling i'm good i'm
good so what's up
so i have told my husband many times
about my love languages he's told me
it's very hard for him to do
and from time to time it makes me feel
unloved how do i navigate this
yeah so what's your love language uh
words of affirmation and physical touch
okay and why does he say he can't do
that
he says it's hard for him because he
didn't grow up
with that sort of love language um
and my family was always really into
those two
specifically yeah so
man i nicole i really wish i was talking
to him right now
um
there's no other word for it other than
it's just being selfish
it sucks okay um i wish there was
something else i could tell you
i hope you'll tell him to call me
someday um okay
it's real annoying for me um it's really
annoying for you too you're living with
it but it's frustrating when any wife
has the courage and vulnerability to
tell their husband hey here's what i
need
when any husband has the courage and
vulnerability to tell their spouse
here's what i need and the other one
just goes nah i'm not going to do that
oh my gosh nicole it drives me crazy it
really does
um but here's the thing he's not on the
phone with me and so i can't
talk to him directly and so i can tell
you what you can do
okay okay um the first thing is
do your best to have a
conversation that he can understand that
he can hear okay
and sometimes these love language
conversations come about
when people are exhausted or frustrated
or at the end of their rope
like you needed him to hold you on
monday
you wanted to be sexually intimate on
tuesday and he was playing video games
you wanted to
him just to tell you look nice on
wednesday fill in the blank and then
friday
it just becomes an explosion right yeah
instead of that conversation
set a time and this is a great season to
do this my wife and i take a retreat
every year
we will go to multiple coffee shops
we'll go to multiple places and it's
almost like a progressive
day and we will just talk about
different topics here's what worked well
this year here's where i want to lean
into being a better husband better
partner better parent this year
here's what i want to do professionally
this year and we just talk about those
things
this would be a great opportunity for
you all to do that
yeah if you will say hey i wanna have a
little miniature retreat this year
and we can talk about things that we
love and don't love and it sets the
table for
i know you don't know how to do these
things i know you didn't grow up in an
affirmative word affirmation house
i know you didn't grow up in a high
touch house
i'm going to teach you how to do these
things
i'm going to teach you with these and it
may be nicole
a humbling process for you it may be you
getting a note card
or a text message that you send him and
say here are things i like to hear
okay and so if you um here are ways i
like you to touch me
and this can be like really vulnerable
this can be almost erotic you can talk
about here's things y'all may have never
had the conversations like hey when
we're
being intimate i really don't like it
when you do this i really love it when
you do that
we've never tried these three things
what are things you'd like to try right
if y'all have never had those type of
conversations this can be a revealing
opening
time and what i would call like one of
those deep roots
conversations that suddenly you get done
from the table and
the roots of your collective tree that
y'all are y'all are managing
have grown way deeper and you didn't
even realize it right but it
starts with an invitation not an attack
okay that starts with i need you to say
these six things and just practice and
it may be
oh nicole this is not romantic and they
don't write this up in the movies this
way
but it may be that you have a note card
that you give him
and when you are hurting you say this is
when
i want you to say this and he'll say it
and then i want you to say nope i want
you to mean it i want you to hug me
tightly
and you are literally walking him
through love language 101
yeah and is that super frustrating and
annoying yes
is that the way it was in titanic or
whatever movies
no but that's you investing and teaching
a guy that you love him the best way he
can love you
okay when i tell you that does that
sound gross and like ugh
or kind of awesome or just the way it's
got to be
no i like that idea i've never thought
of teaching someone a love language
before so i like
that kind of idea sometimes and again i
don't want to gender this because men
and women do this too but often men when
they
don't know how to do something it
translates to i won't
because i feel less than um
it suggests i'm not a man i suggest i'm
emasculated because you're asking me to
do something i don't have the skills to
do so i'm just going to shut it down
right okay and so coming to him as a
teacher
as a and like i say if you make it sexy
if you make it inviting
and not shameful man you're talking
about a whole new avenue of your
relationship you may not even
have experienced before together and
make sure you invite him
to do those things for you what are the
things that really
deepen your heart and make you feel
connected husband what are things that
really get you fired up
when i walk into a room and fill in the
blank what are the things that
make you feel distant and disconnected
when you've had a hard
week at work you've had a frustrating
conversation with your dad
and i say these things and you feel like
i blew you off invite him into those
conversations he's probably
never even thought about those things or
had those conversations especially not
with you
what an awesome gift you could give him
so nicole
this is your new year 2021 you and your
husband are going to learn how to
communicate you're going to be a teacher
for him
again i'm going to say this over and
over everybody listening the world is
not a rom-com it's not a romantic comedy
it's not when we really love people we
have to teach them what that looks like
for us
and sometimes it shifts sometimes my
love language is touch sometimes it is
something else
and sometimes my wife knows oh right now
is when i should hug him and she comes
to hug and i'll say hey
not right now and she's got to know okay
i'm not taking that personal he is being
vulnerable and tell me what he needs
right now and it's not this
great and if we don't take it personal
and we
lean into our partners as though we're
teachers
i mean you're talking about a whole
paradigm shift in relationships which is
awesome
thank you so much for that call nicole
i'm proud of you and then i want you to
call back after your retreat i want you
to have a retreat
call me back and let me know how that
goes i'm
i'm excited to hear how that works man
cause i think your husband's to come
around i'm
optimistic he's going to come around all
right so i want to take this last
segment here
this is a shorter show than normal i'm
not going to just run my mouth
a lot but i want to talk about new
year's coming up
new year's is my favorite time of year
it's it's like we all get this
collective mulligan
it's like no matter how we started we
all get to the end of the year
and you can walk around on january 1st
wearing
all polka dots you can walk around with
a
wheelbarrow full of rocks and someone's
like what are you doing like hey it's
new year's resolution bro and they're
like oh cool man no matter what it is
you're doing
i'm on the all chocolate marshmallow
diet i'm only eating
raw vegetables and ponies and whatever
the thing is you can say whatever you
want everyone's like well that's cool
man whatever
i love new year's but one thing i've
noticed over the last few years is this
obsession
not last few years forever right i've
been obsessed with this forever
but i've noticed it rising to the top
this idea of these
goals we are obsessed with goals
um one of my mentors dr steven bonner
was
called recently and was talking about a
book he was reading
that suggested data is a new
is our new addiction our new cultural
addiction is data
if you can't measure it it's not real
if i can't touch it it's not there if i
can't see it it doesn't exist
and what happens is we get paralyzed
without data companies are just
with a magnifying glass looking at all
of the data so where you used to step
back and look at
trends hey we're all headed this
direction people are
screaming and yelling by every little
nook and cranny
of the every little lightning bolt every
little this and that nest and that and
that and this
and it's making us nuts and it's a
numbing device
i'm not going to move until i look at
the data i'm not going to do anything
until i see the data
we can't do anything unless we got goals
and you can't have goals without metrics
and you can't have metrics without
measurement tools et cetera et cetera
and what happens is we all become
a series of achievements
i wanted to do these things i wanted to
achieve these things i want to look at
my data and decide
am i successful or am i a failure
and i've decided that's a terrible
terrible way to go through life
instead this year i want you to
reimagine
goals i want you to back out of your
life
as a life of only achievement and
successes
and accomplishments and i want you to
begin to think of who
are you now i have not read james
clear's book
called atomic habits i've heard is
excellent and i was talking through this
with somebody the other day and they're
like man
that sounds just like that book so i'm
gonna pick up that book i've actually
met
james like um i know he's a brilliant
guy
and that this book has remained on the
best seller list i think it's pretty
good
and so it may be a worthy read for
everybody i'll go ahead and recommend it
here
but i think what i'm going to talk about
similar and that's this
instead of imagining the goals and
achievements and successes i want you to
begin to think of
who you are and this sounds like
semantics but it's a much
deeper picture instead of asking what am
i going to do this year
i want you to start asking who am i or
what kind of person am i going to be
so here's the way that plays out in real
life instead of looking at your
um your new year's resolutions
i'm gonna lose 35 pounds i'm going to
run a marathon i'm going to bench press
250 pounds
fill in the blank instead i want you to
make your resolution i'm going to commit
to being a person who's a good steward
of my body
i'm going to be a person who commits to
being a good steward of my body
i'm going to be the kind of person that
can play with my grandkids on the ground
when i'm 85.
i'm that kind of person and what you're
going to find is
when you are that kind of person that
kind of person exercises
that kind of person mostly eats right
and
that kind of person dances and plays and
that kind of person
laughs and that kind of person sleeps
so it's a much bigger picture then
underneath that once you've identified
who you want to be what kind of person
are you
what are your values what are your
character then you can set a goal i'm
going to run a marathon with some
friends i want to do something hard
but instead of i want to run two
marathons maybe i want to be the kind of
person who does hard things
who challenges myself
and then training for a marathon is a
hard challenge right
and again it sounds like semantics but
the goal is i'm a person who does hard
things so i was talking to my good
friend george campbell here we were on
another podcast he works here
at ramsey solutions and he was showing
me his
list from last year his resolutions and
they were i'm going to learn this many
songs this week i'm going to
write this much stuff i'm going to this
and this and this and he's like man i
look at this and i
failed 2020. and i was like dude no you
didn't so we stepped back and i said
i'm going to take this i'm going to
write this many songs i'm going to
record an album
i'm going to learn how to play this
guitar solos whatever
and instead of identifying a success or
a failure as
i achieved these things
step back and say i want to be a person
who creates
i want to be a person who is a creative
person
who puts new things out into the world
when i step back and looked at it that
way
with george he's created a ton of new
content
he's spun out a new podcast that he is
leading he has
recorded a number of videos and
um cool ways that that ramsay solutions
is approaching money
he has come up with new stand-up comedy
routines he's been
come up with new things for a number of
live events that he emcees
he's had an incredibly creative year
just didn't write an album and that
doesn't mean he failed this year that
means this year happened to him
and fill in the blank so instead of
saying
i'm going to learn two songs each week
on a guitar i'm going to paint a picture
every week
commit to being a person who creates or
who's creative
because a person will go garden design a
school curriculum come up with
extraordinary work presentations write
grad school papers
figure out how to cook new and inventive
healthy meals
learn what her husband loves or doesn't
love lean into learning a totally new
love language
and that is creative and it may not be
learning a song or two on the guitar
if you want to be a person who does hard
things i'm gonna force myself
i'm gonna force myself to learn a song
every year every every week
all right now you're doing it for a
different reason because you're doing it
for an identity
i commit to being a disciplined person i
commit to being a person who learns
that means i'm going to read i'm going
to listen to podcasts
i'm going to talk to smart people i'm
going to to talk to experienced people
once you've decided who you're going to
be then you get to add some discipline
beneath it that doesn't mean we don't
have goals
it doesn't mean we don't want to achieve
things but that means those come
second those come next to deciding
who do we want to be this year
and so in the next show or two we're
gonna have a new year's special show
because i love new year's
i'm gonna talk about who i'm gonna
commit to be this year
i want you to be thinking through who
are you gonna commit to being
if you're driving in a car back from the
holidays
with your girlfriend or boyfriend or
spouse
only all to talk about who do you want
to be this year
what is the type of person you're going
to commit to being and then what are the
things that you're going to do
underneath that type of commitment
and if you are about the process i'll
end this with the process
so those of you know i attended and
worked at texas tech university
they have a basketball coach there named
chris beard and
you can look it up on youtube it's a
great interview they talked about
somebody's asking how many wins are you
going to have
and he said i don't care and they were
like excuse me you're a division 1
power 5 conference basketball coach
you've won championships everywhere you
went
what do you mean you don't care about
wins he said i care about the process
and he rattled off real quick the
process
every day of his players we will wake up
at 6am we will eat a healthy breakfast
we will
meditate and pray or look at our
affirmations and then we will go
exercise
we will exercise as a team and then we
will go to class we will sit in the
front row and we will wear a tie
and and in and he went about the process
here's the process of being a person of
character here's the process of person
who stewards their body
here's the process of being a teammate
who's not only in this for themselves
but for other people
and if you take care of the process
every day then by and large the winds
will take care of themselves and as he
said
sometimes the ball just bounces out
sometimes the ball just hits somebody's
elbow and bonks off somebody's head and
it goes out of bounds and the game's
over you lose
but if you take care of the process
winds start to take care of themselves
if you get obsessed with winning that's
when you cut corners
that's when you start taking diet pills
to lose weight that's when you starve
yourself
that's when you start looking in the
mirror and thinking i'm not beautiful
i'm not stewarding my body
i'm drawing just to get ripped and you
start
eating things that aren't good for you
you start doing things i just want to be
a better husband
well man then your wife becomes a
project not a partner right
so focus on the process focus on
character focus on who you want to be
focus on what you want to be this year
get somebody you can talk to about it
and we will
put it in concrete we'll write it down
at the next show
so as i wrap up today's show i'm gonna
leave you
man no question one of the greatest
songs of all time
and it's gonna is out in 1988.
not a lot of great music came out in
1988 but we got this one
off the legendary album of the same name
five kids came from up north nkotb
with their classic hanging tough goes
like this
listen up everybody if you want to take
a chance just get on the floor
with the new kids dance don't worry
about nothing because it won't take long
we're going to put you in a trance with
what a funky song
because you got to be hanging tough
hanging tough
are you tough enough everybody's talking
about who's on top
don't cross our path you're gonna get
stomped
whoa donny we ain't gonna give anybody
any slack
if you try to keep us down we're gonna
come right back
and you know we're hanging tough
[Music]
hanging tough are you tough enough this
is the dr john dolone show
you